i would keep what is that seven uh yeah
that's something
i would keep um i would keep
sam raimi's army of darkness a lot of
people say evil dead too
i'm not one of those people
do you still own dvds and blu-rays not
only do i still own dvds and blu-rays
but i buy them
uh constantly and
it can be a little bit of a uh
cause a little bit of friction with my
wife's here
because if we go into a record store
or a dvd or any place where they sell
blu-rays and dvds i'm gonna come out
with at least a dozen
because and the reason is because i
think
and and actually i know and i'm not the
only person who
who feels this way that physical media
is going to go
away in in a in a big way that
blu-rays are going to be i think the
last
high definition or i guess they have
like
ultra high def blu-rays now but this is
really going to be the last
piece of physical media for movies
that we own so i'm buying as many as i
can
and i love you know i love filming my
television
i have oh god hundreds of blu-rays and
dvds in my collection
everything and yeah i just feel like
there's you know it's it's interesting
because i think for like a
like a filmmaker or like a writer or an
actor
you know we use them i use them to like
reference like if i've got an idea
for a scene or for a piece of dialogue
or for a camera move i'm like what
movie have i seen that in oh gosh i
remember they did this really cool dolly
shot
in this movie i go to my collection i
grab it i put it on i watch that part
and i'm like oh yeah that's it
okay cool and then i'll i'll do a shot
list usually i
i do a lot of this even before like
making something like i'd watch
a lot of my favorite films
just so that sort of like
filmic sort of like visual language gets
just quickly imprinted and it's it's
very
um very fresh in my mind
but yeah i love blu-rays and dvds i
always buy them
i buy them as often as i can
what if the technology that you have to
play them on
now you've got this physical media it
breaks down
yeah is there an obscure shop somewhere
that there's going to be a guy that
knows how to fix it what if that goes
away
i think there is i'll learn how to fix
it myself
i'll really no i'm kidding but um i
you know i think um that could happen i
mean
you know like who knows how to work a
vcr anymore you know
how to fix one i don't but i'm sure
there's somebody out there that that's
good at
stuff like that that can do it but um
yeah i i just feel like it's so
important to hang on to
for me at least the physical media
because i do
also own some films as like digital
copies
you know that we have on the cloud or
whatever but i'm always so
nervous of those like um i think it's
more
likely that something might happen and
those get deleted
as opposed to my physical media which is
like a tangible
disc that i can hold in my hand
so yeah i i love it and
it's never going to go away for me it's
never going to go away like i
um i'm going to keep on buying blu-rays
until they
stop making them how do you have it
organized
i you know i don't have it organized i
do have it organized
by um blu-rays and dvds
and i try not to as best i can because i
have a lot
and it is kind of like a problem for me
like i said whenever i go anywhere
and if they sell blu-rays or dvds i'm
gonna get some but uh
i try not to buy things that i have on
dvd again on blu-ray
even though i might want to because
there has to be some
point that i cut myself off otherwise
i'm just gonna
buy all these movies that i already own
so i try and
try not to do that there's there are
quite a few that i i do own both
but i do have them organized by dvds and
i have my blu-rays
and but that's it like i don't get into
alphabetizing
or um doing it by genre that's too much
that's a little too much work for me and
i don't have that much time
um even in the pandemic i didn't do that
but
boy i i watched i watched them a lot
and like every you know every like on a
friday night like we'll just i'll pull
like
a stack of like i don't know
10 and probably watch about half of them
i love it i love it
let's say you were only allowed to keep
10 movies
what ten would you keep if i was only
allowed to keep ten movies
out of my blu-ray or dvd collection i
would keep
i would keep probably all oh man that's
tough i would keep
oh gosh oh man that's so hard because
you know there's comedies that i love
watching
but like like maybe i would keep like my
favorites um i would keep
okay i would keep um here we go
i can do it top top 10 that blu-rays or
dvds i would keep i would keep
um i would keep
wes anderson's rushmore i would keep
that
i would keep um
paul thomas anderson's boogie nights
i would keep um martin scorsese's taxi
driver
i would keep um
i would keep mike nichols the graduate i
would keep oliver stone's wall street
i would keep michael mann's less than
mohicans
i would keep james cameron's terminator
two
i would keep what is that seven uh yeah
that's something
i would keep um i would keep
sam raimi's army of darkness a lot of
people say evil dead too
i'm not one of those people um i would
keep
what is that eight uh now you're on nine
mm-hmm
oh that was nine or this is not this is
not okay so i would keep
oh man you got two more i know
i would keep um alexander payne sideways
and maybe something something different
um there's a movie that i loved it's not
super popular i don't
not not too many people maybe
have heard of it or have seen it yet but
[Music]
he's a he's an actor filmmaker his name
is richard ayawade and he made a movie
called
submarine and i just it's
it's probably the most recent movie in
that list
that i would keep but i just loved it so
i would keep submarine
those are my ten is that it's like a one
location
film no no it's a it's a really
wonderful story about kind of a teenage
outcast
or a teenage sort of a kind of a awkward
kid in high school
who you know it's sort of like a high
school
romance love story just about this kind
of offbeat quirky kid
who's kind of sort of trying to find
himself and dealing with
issues with his parents but he he's also
dealing with this
this girl that he really likes who's
who's sort of like
kind of like a little um i mean she's
just very like sort of like mischievous
and sort of like really like um
kind of like cocky and and just really
like um
kind of dangerous for him you know not
not like him
um he's sort of more of a uh oh
kind of kind of quiet
kid um but it's just it's
it's made with such great visuals and
just
so much personality and such great music
um i think it's like one of those movies
that just like
to me it's like explodes off the screen
just i like from the
first moment it was on i was like i love
this so
that's that's my number 10. do you still
have vhs
no i don't i got rid of my vhs i i used
to have a
i used to have a ton even when i was a
little boy i loved
collecting vhs movies even before i
became an actor i mean i really
you know i've always loved films and
television so
now no vhs no no vcr
yeah i don't know if i would even really
enjoy watching them because i think i've
gotten so used to the high def
blu-ray quality that we i think any of
us you know anybody any filmmakers out
there watching this
i don't know if i would really enjoy
going back and watching those but
yeah i got rid of them i do i have a lot
i feel very strongly that like
we really do need if you if people have
them they should really hang on to them
because as we see it now
you know studios are releasing stuff
exclusively on netflix or exclusively on
amazon prime or exclusively on
hulu or whatever it is and i just don't
think those films
are going to get a blu-ray copy i don't
think they're going to get a physical
copy so
i really do think that people should if
they you know
i think they should really hang on to
their collections because i i think this
is going to be it
and what's the most you've ever paid i
remember paying 90
for a dvd back in the day yeah and i had
to order them on amazon this is about
oh my gosh no i've never paid that it
was a long time ago but i really wanted
it
and what's the most you ever paid oh man
i don't know
i think i bought like very you know
fancy packaging um the most i've ever
paid for something
is probably for a single dvd or blu-ray
i don't know maybe 50 or something like
that okay
but like that's for like a limited
edition
you know fancy box set whatever but um
but yeah it's always money well spent i
think
spending money on dvds and blu-rays
is totally fine
because uh because you know it's
it's something that you're gonna have
forever and it's gonna bring you so much
joy
you can watch it time and time again if
you're making something you can always
go back and reference it if there's
something
you really loved um i just think it's
it's just totally worth it to me
and um yeah you'll have to ask sarah
about that or my wife about that
because uh yeah i spend you know
spend a lot of money on blu-rays but i
think it's
okay
you